so it's a maximum question right so
don't take shortcuts at this point
i want to find stationary points so i
should say
for stationary points well really you
could say
for turning points but anyway potential
turning points
for stationary points
my derivative will be equal to zero
okay now i'm just going to skip a step
um but i'm going to tell you what it is
so you shouldn't
but it's just so that i don't have to
write so much because it takes me
forever up here
because what i want is the whole
derivative should be zero right
as richard was mentioning there's no
value i can put in the denominator
that's going to make it equal to zero
right so i don't care what the
denominator is so long as the numerator
is zero and then
the denominator can be whatever you like
so it's really just this part that i'm
interested in
okay that's the that's my numerator okay
so
for that to be zero i'm going to get
this
okay now i'm going to get on to that in
a second but before i do that
i think i'll try a couple of other
markers
see if they work better i don't need
that
um now here's where we got in trouble
right at this point you think two
problems number one
x to the four really gross you start to
think okay
i could do like a let u equal x squared
make that substitution then this will
turn into a u this will turn into a u
squared and then it'll sort of be a
quadratic
but you still end up having this other
huge problem or division in this
square root that's awful okay that's
really hard to solve
um the way that you get rid of it is
going to be really really decisive it's
going to tell you whether you get the
answer in
like eight lines or in like 18 lines
okay
so here's what i'm going to suggest um
and i'm going to start
well try this one i'm going to keep this
x squared over the other side
okay so i'm going to get two yeah that's
much better
2x to the four i'm not going to do the
substitution because i don't feel it
actually
um after giving it a go it doesn't make
it a whole lot
simpler just the numbers are slightly
smaller
now what could i do here right to get
rid of the fraction
one thing i could do is multiply through
by the denominator
okay and that would make some things
better right for one it would get rid of
this fraction
the two it would get rid of this being
the square root okay so that's
good okay but there's a problem right
what's the problem with multiplying
through by the square root
specifically which part of the numerator
um
this guy right because this will get
simpler this will get simpler and then
the square root just goes over here
now you're like one square root is
better than two that's true
but you're basically back where you
started okay you still got this enormous
radical sign it's hard to get rid of
okay
yeah um can't you just add times
the denominator and put it everything
over to x
multiply this denominator here by one
by one times that
here yeah yeah okay i can't you mean put
these on a common denominator
that'll be fine but i still will not get
rid of my square root zone
it'll still be sitting there in the
denominator it's going to sit somewhere
it's my point
now here's here's the tricky thing okay
and i think this is what you're missing
which is why the
answer eluded you um multiplying through
isn't the answer and this actually comes
up in some lockers questions
as well even though it's a bit
counterintuitive what you really need to
do at this point
this is why i move the x squared over on
this side
is you need to square everything
everything okay now you usually think
that's a bad idea in this case
okay because squaring right hand side no
big deal let's go to the left-hand side
okay now if i'm okay you're doing
twice as much work to get the same
result at the end it's just gonna have
higher powers that's all
okay the reason why is there's something
important about these two things that
when i put them together yeah there's um
well it's on the denominator it's on the
numerator that's important because think
about once
what happens okay let's square this out
let's do it um when i square
a plus b all squared right what's that
equal to a squared
plus two a b plus b squared
okay so think about this with me here's
my a
so let's square it the whole lot okay so
what happens
you get four x to the
a eight okay i know that looks bad
be patient with it okay it's it's sort
of like you're introducing this problem
but you're going to get rid of a bigger
one okay so it's like a tray sort of
um what happens to the dynamite well the
square root sign just disappears
so voila
okay so there's my um there's my a
squared now what happens to the 2a b
this is really good for us right because
when i multiply these two together
the square root just disappears okay so
i'm going to
multiply them together and double yeah
so i'll get
minus 4 x to the fourth
okay yeah all the other things have come
out of the wash
and then lastly i've got a plus b
squared so square it
and that's what i get
okay is that all right what happens to
the right hand side well minus
that's going to disappear that's just an
x to the four
okay so that looks a little more
workable
i know there's that eight okay but at
least there's no square root signs
and importantly even though there's an
eight there are fours here
it's all even powers this is kind of
like an equation reducible to a
quadratic
still okay
okay now as it turns out i don't
actually need to do
much uh like fancy footwork if i just
want to play out
and simplify um this 4x38 will disappear
okay but stay with me
so let's see here um
let's before i multiply through i'll
i'll simplify a little bit so
4x to the 8 on this guy
what have i got here minus four x to the
four
this x to the four and this axis of four
should cancel all right
yep so minus four x to the four
plus eighty one okay
now multiply through
so what do i got here i'm gonna get i'm
gonna put this all together
is that okay yes now i know that looks
terrible too
but it's terrible in exactly the right
way that we need can you see why
right because that x to the 4 and that
minus x to the 4
that's going to be the x to the 8 that i
needed right so
4x to the 8 out the front but this by
this
minus 4x to the 8th this by that
324
and i don't know what 81 squared is but
someone can tell me
okay some number
um okay now cancel cancel
that's a relief thank you
81-324 they're all multiples of this is
minus 243
plus is that okay
this is starting to look a little more
manageable and these are these are all
divisible by yeah okay so
i'm pretty sure this is where it turns
out i'm pretty sure that's where it goes
because i remember i looked at the
answer this is how you get there though
okay
so it's the fourth root of 27.
what a terrible number but then again we
shouldn't be surprised that that
it should be so weird like for number
one the fourth route is because
there's a four that's why okay
um no that's that's the cube root it's
the fourth root
um but from there i think you can handle
it right
you can test on either side i guess we
wouldn't want to use the second
derivative but i think you know what to
do
okay
ah yes good question um you're right
you're right it is plus or minus but
then because from memory i think x is a
length in this case or something like
that right
so i can exclude the negative result
so you're right to mention it like i
should have mentioned it too
and then say it's only the positive one
because of this reason
okay
um
okay so what's the moral of the story um
a couple of things be careful with your
algebra you'd be so frustrated if um
you were going through all of this work
and it was just your derivative that you
got wrong
that'd be really frustrating and it's
not an easy derivative to get um
secondly when you see all of these
square roots and that kind of thing okay
you've got to know there's more than one
way to get rid of them right and
squaring out even though usually it's
sort of counterintuitive
it's just the kind of twist you would
expect for a final question in the game
okay